[Music]
while the vast majority of car mechanics
are decent and reliable it's a sad but
true fact that some are not if you're
unlucky enough to have your car left in
the garage days after you took it in
with bills mounting up unnecessarily
you'll know what we mean be sure to
watch this video until the end to find
out how some fuel has a misleading name
if this is your first time visiting the
thingsand please give this video a like
and hit the subscribe button here are 10
ways your car mechanic is ripping you
off on their regular beware the idiot
light one of the most unnerving things
that can happen to a driver is finding
out the check engine light is turned on
that's the yellow light that comes on
when a range of problems are triggered
the thing is this light can refer to a
multitude of errors it could be a major
part of the car such as the catalytic
converter in need of repair this is
something that could potentially cost a
lot of money equally though it could be
that there's a loose connection of some
kind in the sensor wires the problem is
that without having a proper look at
your car you won't know this isn't one
of the lights where there can only be
really one thing wrong so if it does
come on and it stays on then you should
take it to the garage as soon as
possible however this is definitely a
case where you hope you have a
scrupulous mechanics most garages will
charge to diagnose the problem which
could be fixed by simply resetting the
code however an undercover study made by
American broadcasters ABC found that
some garage is charged for doing work
that didn't need to be done after what
some called the idiot light lit up it
can be easy to feel helpless in these
situations so you do have to hope you
have a trustworthy mechanic okay guys we
are so excited to announce we're
producing our
with no content head over to the trendy
for the best bi wise fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more
we are sure you're going to love it a
battery you don't need it's the sound
that every motorist dreads you turn the
keys and your ignition and it shutters
and it clanks and then nothing that's
the sound of a flat battery maybe you've
left the lights on accidentally or
perhaps you've been waiting around with
the engine off and you've been listening
to the radio sometimes you can get lucky
and a fellow motorist will help give you
a kickstart but sometimes that just
isn't possible so you call your
breakdown people now most reliable
breakdown companies will be able to give
you a jumpstart and if that doesn't work
they'll test the battery only if it
doesn't respond to the test then it
should be ripped out of your engine and
thrown away however not all breakdown
companies can be trusted shockingly an
investigation in 2016 found that one of
Britain's biggest car breakdown
companies we're telling people to ditch
perfectly good batteries married couple
John and Sheila Smith suffered a
breakdown and when the company's patrol
van came to see them they said there was
a faulty cell in the battery mr. Smith
was suspicious and when he went to the
shop he bought the battery from they
found it was fine an investigation by
the watchdog consumers rights TV show
found eight out of ten roadside repairs
tried to sell people new batteries when
they didn't need them the RAC says it
has sophisticated testing technology and
stood by its staff air-filter Khan one
of the most overlooked parts of a car is
the air filter this contraption
featuring rows and rows of specially
created paper doesn't sound like a
glamorous thing to have in your vehicle
but it really is crucial anyone who's
ever been in the car which didn't have
one will know there's a big difference
the filter removes things such as dust
pollen mold and dangerous vapors from
the engine and stops them going into the
main part of the car without them
drivers and passengers will experience
what some petrol has called motor breath
which is when all the gunk are usually
insulated from hits you trust us it is
extremely unpleasant
now most decent garages will include an
air filter change when your car gets is
annual service however the relative
obscurity of the air filter means that
it is a prime target for the sort of
mechanics who will rip you off some of
the scams are not uncommon for instance
a car might be taken in for something
else and the staff at the repair shop
will actually dirty up the
to make you get a new one or they'll
tell you that they've changed the filter
charging you for it when they've left
the old one in there our advice
if in doubt try to change the air filter
yourself this may not be possible on all
cars though test drive becomes Joyride
the whole point of going to a mechanic
to get your car fixed is to make sure
that it can be driven effectively and
safely this seems self-evident really
and if your car is causing you problems
it can be a relief albeit an expensive
one to find it repaired and it's natural
for the mechanic to give it a test-drive
afterwards just to make sure that the
problem has been solved however you have
to hope that you've got a fixer who is
not going to take liberties because
sometimes the test drives can sadly turn
into joyrides there have been cases
where a mechanic has taken a high-end
car and a far longer journey than the
repairs warrant and because the trip has
been a long when there's been an
accident lawyer Steve Leto tells the
story of a client who took a brand-new
Corvette into the body shop because a
rearview mirror was vibrating sounds
like a pretty minor repair right
however the mechanics took the car for a
drive and then managed to wreck it
luckily percieves client the company
settled outside of court it may not
happen to you but be careful that you
trust your garage enough you don't want
them to rack up a bill for a dent or
even for them to leave you're having to
buy more gasoline than is needed
unnecessary headlight cleaner sometimes
it's nice to get a bit more than you
expected when we pay for services it's
always a good thing when someone goes
the extra mile however it's not so nice
to get a bill for something that you
didn't need or even ask for when it
comes to visiting mechanic sometimes
they'll charge you lots for something
that should cost very little for
instance if you see a charge because
they've cleaned your dirty windows
that's a problem what's even worse is
when there's a charge for cleaning
headlights did you know that you can do
this using an everyday household item
that's right if you hit the lights with
toothpaste you can get them clean again
this is because toothpaste contains a
very mild abrasive substance that helps
to read your teeth of Monk that same
thing will also do exactly the same for
the headlights of your car if they get
dirty what you have to do is pretty
simple if you watch the lights with
soapy water first that'll help but then
you should put some toothpaste on a wet
cloth and give your lights a good
rubdown it should take about 10 minutes
but it will work that'll save you a bit
of a bill and it's good to know that you
can do that thing yourself rather than
get ripped off by a dodgy garage scratch
fever today we have been looking at the
sort of thing that unscrewed
garages mechanics and body shops can rip
you off these are usually the kind of
things that could happen to pretty much
any motorists with pretty much any make
and model of car however if you're the
sort of driver who sees a small scratch
on their car and says so what then this
may not affect you so much but the rest
of us should be very wary of getting
small tiny cosmetic nips scratches and
the like repaired after all if you've
got a slightly older car than these
sorts of things are to be expected
however you might have got some things
that just can't be put down to the
passage of time you might have a load of
very large scratches or you might have
the sort of dents that actually impact
on your car's performance however you
need to be careful there are been
reports of charges of more than $1,000
for easing out a small cosmetic scratch
the thing is this is one of the cases
where you might well find yourself as a
hostage to fortune we know that getting
the right kind of car paint may not be
easy but this is a big example of a
piece of work costing way more than it
should sparkplugs if you have got a car
then you will know just how important it
is to keep the little bits and bobs
under the bonnet in good condition they
are things that might not look like much
but can make a big difference in terms
of your vehicle safety and reliability
however there's one thing that some
mechanics might tell you to do that you
don't need unless your car is really old
there's something that everyone has
heard of and that's the spark plug these
little things were something that needed
to be changed every year at one point
that's because back in the day engines
didn't burn gasoline that efficiently
that meant that when it was time for the
annual service the plugs would end up
being blackened from carbon that was and
still is a sign that they needed to be
switched around normally if you've got a
mechanic was been around for a long time
you might give them the benefit of the
doubt however for a more contemporary
garage owner there can't really be any
sort of excuse the fact if your car has
been running for less than a hundred
thousand miles you shouldn't need new
spark plugs if your mechanics as you do
then it might see that your car has some
other problems that need solving
otherwise they might be trying to rip
you off manipulating figures we all like
it when our car works perfectly but of
course there are going to be times when
it doesn't that's what we have to take
it into the garage now it may be the
case that you will need to have some
work done in a part of the car that is
quite hard to get into for instance if
you need your water pump replaced or fix
then it can be quite hard to get to it
so your mechanic will charge you a
decent amount for service and labor
that's because the garage will have to
take out a number of older parts before
they can get to the pump itself now if
these parts are showing serious signs of
wear and tear or if they have got
damaged
it's sensible and right to get this seen
to at the same time as the water pump
when you get the bill it should charge
you for all the parts and for the labor
and service required to take the water
pump out however a big warning sign
would be if there's a charge for service
and labor for all the parts there
shouldn't be any confusion in any way
whatsoever the work taking them out and
putting them in should be covered by the
cost of the original work steering wheel
problems whenever you think of driving
there's one part of a car that oddly
gets overlooked sometimes that is the
steering wheel it's probably the single
most important driver operated part of
the car well okay the brakes are crucial
when it comes to safety but at the end
of the day driving is about motion and
driving would be boring not to mention
just a little bit pointless if you
weren't able to steer the car anywhere
however the thing about steering wheels
is that any potential problems are
hidden in a place where you the driver
can't see them so it is a quick
money-making exercise by crooked
mechanics to charge for steering rack
bearings the can't be seen so it is
quite straightforward to get them fixed
even if they actually aren't there are
other things that fall into this
category too we're talking about the
likes of the tailgate struck the water
pump the door hinge mounting and even
the wheel bearing of course it is always
possible that these things might
genuinely need some work just because
you don't know what's going wrong that
doesn't automatically mean that it isn't
going wrong however be aware that if a
lot of these things are listed on your
next repair bill if they are then it is
possible that you and your mechanic have
reached the end of the line fuel types
today we have been talking about how
some unscrupulous mechanics will use
people's lack of knowledge when it comes
to vehicles to make a quick buck usually
it's done for making repairs that aren't
needed or by charging over the odds for
service and labor however there is one
thing that some high-end body shops
sometimes do that can hike up charges
sometimes if a car is having a lot of
work that petrol tank will need to be
drained that will mean that a garage
might give you some gasoline if you're
lucky it's included in the price of the
work however if you are really unlucky
you'll get hit with a charge for premium
fuel a survey from the American
Automobile Association found that
motorists in the USA paid an extra two
point 1 billion dollars in 2016 for this
stuff the thing is it's not really any
better for your car than the fuel you're
already using the triple-a is managing
director of automotive engineering and
repair John Nielsen said drivers who saw
the name premium at the gasoline pump
were often mistaken they thought the
fuel was a higher quality when in fact
it was just higher octane mr. Nielsen's
advice was to check the owner's manual
to see which gasoline works best for
your car that kind of thinking when have
you been caught out by a misleading name
let us know in the comment and that's
all for our 10 ways your car mechanic is
ripping you off on the regular if you
enjoyed it why not check out 20 genius
car cleaning hacks thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]